if the world warms five degrees to
massive uninhabitable zones spread into
ones temperate regions of the northern
and southern hemispheres snowpack and
aquifers that feed the world's great
cities Los Angeles Cairo Lima Bombay are
drying out climate refugees number in
the hundreds of millions this could be
our world plus five degrees I think in a
world which is much warmer than now fire
degrees it's going to be inconceivable
that human civilization can withstand
that kind of a climatic shock
[Music]
now we enter the twilight zone of
climate change a nightmare vision of
life on Earth
perhaps most frightening of all is how
much we can't know traditional social
systems would break down
I think it's the poor everywhere that
are going to suffer because if you take
the example of say Hurricane Katrina
which I'm not saying was necessarily
caused by human induced climate change
who were the worst sufferers in the city
of New Orleans the poorest of the poor
they were just left behind the best way
to survive the catastrophe of a hotter
planet is to prevent it from happening
in the first place
failing that we may be confronting far
more difficult choices
you